okay he's almost like this I was hanging
out with some friends I was dressed like
this and I lacked the motivation to
dress into my normal video attire so you
get overdressed me for this video but if
you have the opportunity to ever over
dress for any given situation I suggest
you take it makes life a little fun
[Music]
the wolf among us chapter 2 smoking
mirrors so the wolf among us chapter 2
picks up where Chapter 1 left off and
I'm gonna have some spoilers in here for
people who have not played chapter 1 if
you haven't played chapter one I suggest
you do that ad or if you're gonna watch
this video just know I'm gonna spoil
some so chapter 1 ended we saw Snow
White's head on a porch we were all just
like or something like that it's pretty
much exactly like that and now in
chapter 2 Bigby wolf is determined he's
like I'm gonna find out who's killing
folks because Bigby wolf hates a killer
who takes head and doesn't give it so
now in Chapter 2 you're in full
investigative mode which makes chapter 2
less exciting than chapter 1 chapter 1
you had a fight you had a throwdown
right out the gate then you had a chase
sequence and you had another fight in a
bar with Grendel in this one it's more
investigative you're asking questions
you had the opportunity to be a dick
about it
now you can punch people you can be bad
cop but really chapter 2 is all about
fleshing out Big B Wolf's character in
terms of how you want to play him I for
one I was like I don't see a reason to
be a douchebag I don't want to be a dick
I want to be psychological that's how
I'm gonna get out of these people it was
never that one guy who owned the bar I'd
punched him and made him drop his
boombox
then I smashed his TV I guess I was a
little rude to him but he was an
that I was relatively more or less nice
in this episode which I like I mean Big
B's a sheriff so you got a do police
work investigative type which I
find really fascinating you're piecing
together Clues you're asking people
questions there is a fight that you get
into in this episode but it's not like
chapter 1 I mean you're fighting gruntal
in the bar in chapter 1 I can go Quan
Chi on his ass I can rip his limbs off
and beat him to death with it I don't
care but in this episode the fight that
you get into you look at him you're like
I don't want to hurt you I even gave the
guy a couple of free hits cuz I felt
like he needed it that's the kind of guy
Bigby wolf is he's nice like that he'll
give you hits on him if you really need
it oh than all the wolf among us chapter
2 is a good chapter to I mean chapter
once an introduction you see how the
game plays you get into a couple of
fights you ask a few questions you see
how the overall mechanic is gonna work
chapter 2 delves deeper into Big B
Wolf's character and unless you make
monumental character choices for him
which you feel like you're gonna follow
you throughout the game I was impressed
with the wolf among us chapter 2 and
again it ends off and one of those
cliffhanger moments where you're like
holy
Chapter three I hope Chapter three isn't
three months down the road like from
chapter one to two was I need that
now still impressed and still not going
to rate the game up until the entire
game is done five chapters all in all
people we're almost there
kind of not really that probably gonna
be here before they all come out so the
wolf among us chapter two smoking
mirrors have you played it what did you
think about and were you good cop this
time around we used to like no Bigby
wolf stands for big bad wolf and I'm
gonna be a big bad douche bag you can be
a big bad if you want it's
within your right to do so whatever you
thought however you played it comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]